have you guys ever had a side chick or
been a side chick
yeah I've had a side chick I see you
have yeah yeah
I have
well I did not plan this at all
wow okay okay go ahead uh no no official
side chick
with multiple things at the same time
okay unofficial
yeah no I've never had a side chick per
se but juggling yeah but not side chick
I would say yes so when you guys hear
side chick is when I think of side chick
I think there's like a main chick and
then like they're like you know exactly
because I don't think it's a side chick
if you you juggle multiple wouldn't that
I actually have a question do you guys
think what's the difference between a
side chick a mistress and a sneaky link
there's a side chick Mitch isn't a
sneaky link he said what's the
difference yeah side chick is when
you've got a girl and and then you've
got another girl as well on the side
that doesn't necessarily know about the
yeah they don't know about each other
okay Mysteries more for married people
if you're married and you've got a side
chick it's a mistress okay kind of
upgraded side chick
because when I think of a sneaky link
like that is they're not in a
relationship it's just like yeah that's
just somebody you sneak around with late
nights past 11 o'clock
okay so question for the guys that said
yes to having a side chick
what
made you want to get a side chick
um was your girlfriend not doing
something
that's usually the reason for a side
chick because you know like if you if
you get into a relationship with a girl
she kind of gives you like a terms and
conditions list like without even saying
it really so you know what you can kind
of get from your main goal because you
know in
return you you know you're taking her
out in public whereas your side chick
she doesn't really care about being out
in public and she might do the things
that your main girl might not so that's
kind of how she might have crept into
you know being my side chick by doing
the stuff my main thing wasn't doing
could I have an example of something
um
learning when
to be quiet
okay no just accepting something and
just being like all right cool so you're
just leaving it so your main girl was
always arguing with you yeah and so like
that just got tiring so then you were
like I need to find someone who gives me
peace some peace and quiet and so why
did you not promote the side chick to
Maine
because
being a side chick
you can't really okay promote once you
come in as a side chick you're never
coming out nah you're never coming out
you're never coming out the site you're
staying in the friend zone absolutely
men we have that I'll be putting them in
the side chick friend zone too once
you're in there you come in that gate
you leave in that gate you know what I
mean so so what do you guys think can
um a side chick be promoted to Main
Chick
go ahead
nah simple as simple as that I don't
think so no side chicks if if it's a
girl that is um that you don't uh
necessarily respect enough to be your
actual wife then she's not that's not
what she's for she's for she serves a
purpose they're usually not as good
looking as well it's like usually a
Walmart version of your girlfriend yeah
if your main girl leaves you and you
Splunk with your misses
it would decide the side chick is going
to become your main goal anyway
yeah that turns into a sneaky link
and then you go and watch someone else
you know I mean
[Laughter]
um what about you guys so being on the
other end of that what was it like being
a side chick horrendous horrendous I
think being a side chick you still class
yourself as even though you know your
side chick you still like to think that
you're their main girl or you're the
person bringing all the fun to them so
it still feels like you're their main
girl but then you know it's never going
anywhere you're never stepping out of
that zone because you let yourself come
into that zone that's always the problem
why'd you stay
uh because it's fun yeah and and I think
a part of you still hopes that you might
they might promote you to their main
chick but that never happens ever so
absolutely
um for me it was it was fine because I
knew what I was getting into
um I knew I was the side chick and I
didn't want nothing else and it was what
it was so for me it was fine but I think
if you understand going in that you're
not going to be upgraded and you're not
emotionally attached to the person like
try not to get emoji attached then you
can do it successfully yeah
okay blessing I know you're fixing the
camera but I need you to pull the yeah
yeah
so we have a video we're gonna react to
I just want to see everyone's
it's called
um
side chicks have high self-esteem yeah
what up YouTube
it's a big homie AP
and this is for all the women
that think that side chicks have low
self-esteem
okay
I've heard that [ __ ] so many times in my
life
or when I talk about the women I've
dated and [ __ ] and women say I mean
that's that type of woman I mean you you
know that those women have low
self-esteem to [ __ ] with somebody like
you and this that and the other
let me explain this [ __ ] so y'all can
finally get an understanding and and
understand that these women have the
highest self-esteem
okay
first of all
a woman that is a quote-unquote side
chick
she doesn't go into this situation like
oh man I can't get a man for myself so
uh I might as well latch on to somebody
else [ __ ] or uh you know
uh you know I don't deserve a man of my
own so I might as well deal with whoever
will [ __ ] with me that's not their
[ __ ] attitude all right they
attitude is like well [ __ ] if he talking
to me
if he given me time and attention if he
willing to take me out if you're willing
to spend money on me
somebody ain't handling their [ __ ]
business at home you know what I'm
saying and that might not be true but
this is how they think this is how a
woman feels she might feel like or you
know what
[ __ ] he might got a chick now
he might like his check
but when he gets some of this [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying or we or when
when he get when he get a dose of me
man he ain't going home you know what
I'm saying he gonna he gonna call her up
like on Harlem Nights likes like yeah
baby I ain't coming home you know what
I'm saying so
that's the that's the mentality of a
side chick not no uh oh I I I can't get
a man of my own or you know all that
kind of dumb [ __ ] these women go in like
well [ __ ] he can't he can't be too happy
if he barking up my tree you know he
calling my phone all the [ __ ] time he
seemed to be always available for me
you know what I'm saying they damn never
start feeling like man that can't be
serious what they got
you know if he if he coming at me this
hard they can't be straight
but never are these women
are down and out feeling like they can't
get another man or get a man of their
own most of them have options
most of these women
not every man is qualified
okay and not only are
do uh side chicks have high self-esteem
they're real good at math
let me explain why side chicks are so
good at math okay
I should have did the real numbers but
let's let's just assume there's
so many million men in the United States
and so many million women
now out of those millions of men
subtract the man that are married
okay
now subtract the men that are gay
now subtract the men that are under five
foot
five
then subtract the man
that are attractive
or or unattractive subtract the ugly
[ __ ]
then subtract the people with
disabilities the males that you know the
disabled men
then subtract the men that are you know
either crazy or or or you know mentally
disabled
now subtract all the men or males that
are under
20 under under 18 I should say
now subtract the man that got jobs or or
you know the men that don't got jobs
subtract them man
who
[Laughter]
subtract the man who know how to talk to
women okay
then subtract the man who uh
have an education a high school diploma
or a job you know what I'm saying the
point I'm trying to make
is by the time you subtract all of these
undesirable men
y'all have a extremely small pool and
then I ain't get into the [ __ ] in jail
okay so y'all have the smallest pool of
men to choose from
just off top man that you would actually
want and be happy with are very very
limited in the United States really all
over the world but we're talking about
here okay
so now you saying this woman that's a
side chick
she got low self-esteem
I think she just good at math I think
she realized there is a limited amount
of quality men
and if she's gonna want one for herself
she's gonna have to get out there and
compete for him
and the women that say stupid [ __ ] like
see I that's why I don't need no man I'm
just I'm just be by myself then to do
all that you know what that tell me you
got low self-esteem
because if you had high self-esteem
you're afraid to get out here and
compete
compete you wouldn't be afraid to get
get your hair done and your nails done
and put on some clothes and go out here
and take you a [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying you got low self-esteem
that's what the [ __ ] I heard when you
said I just be by myself then because
you don't think you got what it takes to
get a man you don't think you got what
it takes to to out-compete another woman
you know what I'm saying as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible